hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry where we're
going to be examining and analyzing
everything that is happening in Russia
at the moment
we will also be taking your questions as
well so if you've got questions send us
a Super Chat send us a PayPal and in the
second half of the interview we'll be
feeding your questions to Constantine
and we'll be discussing them so that is
your chance to ask constant questions
all about what is happening
but I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantine
kissing that was smooth mate yeah you're
interest sounded like it was a little
bit of slow motion but anyway here we
are yeah indeed we should probably
announce that actually I mean if people
were tuning in to find out about the
terrible emergency coup as we speak the
guy who's orchestrating the crews just
said he's turning his troops around so
you can switch off basically but
seriously though if you want to
understand what's happening that's what
we were going to talk about absolutely
that is what we were going to talk about
because I think a lot of people are kind
of in the what sitting at home they woke
up a few hours ago they have no clue
what's happened they don't know who the
Wagner group is they don't know who
Afghani precaution is so let's start
with that who is The Afghani precaution
well he is so we should start with the
Wagner Wagner whatever where you
pronounce it so they are a private
military company basically a mercenary
group that Putin has been funding for a
long time in order to participate in
conflicts and train troops and so on
around the world so that Russia could do
things in places like Syria and various
countries in Africa without actually
that being attributable to the Russian
military yeah and so they've been
operating uh as I say in various
different parts of the world but most
prominently in Syria where they actually
um I did a whole tweet series about this
today they actually uh at one point
found themselves in direct confrontation
with American forces and uh had took
very heavy casualties in that battle but
basically put very simply they're a
private mercenary company there's been
uh fighting in different places around
the world and when Russia invaded
Ukraine in uh March of last year or
February of last year
um in February of last year
uh they were one of the key units that
did a lot of the fighting on the front
lines uh and they because they're very
well funded and they're very well
trained and very experienced they were
actually one of the units that had some
of the biggest successes While most of
the Russian military actually really
really struggled uh and was forced to
see territory that are initially
occupied back to the ukrainians the
Wagner group was one of the group the
units that's been very successful for a
number of reasons one of them is uh
they're not subject to various rules of
war and regulations and so
um they've been able to use very brutal
tactics so uh the other we'll get to
back to that in a second but the other
reason is
they uh had for a long time they were
able to recruit convicts and evgan
progression who's the head of this group
uh he is actually an ex-convict himself
so he would go to these penal colonies
all over Russia into prisons all over
Russia and he would say well you are
here for murder or you were here for
assault or whatever you've got another
10 years on your sentence uh why don't
you come and do six months with me
you'll be paid you'll be well trained
much better trained than if you were in
a regular army uh but much better
equipped and if you do six months with
me you can go home and you get a pardon
so your sentence is completely commuted
as a result which obviously as you can
imagine to some prisoners that would
have been quite appealing and they did
that for a long time
uh and what they did with uh with the
units is basically they use style and
tactics so if you retreat they they just
show you so and he told people when he
was recruiting them at the prison he
would be like no retreat if you're
Retreat we're going to shoot you and and
they do this uh they they're one of the
things they're known for is they execute
uh the factors or anyone who surrenders
and then says anything bad about them by
Smashing their head in with a
sledgehammer live on camera and they
publish several of these episodes
um so very brutal very professional and
they were fighting over the city in
eastern Ukraine quite a small City
actually called Bachmann for about eight
months which was longer than the Battle
of Stalingrad uh and and a few weeks ago
they managed to force the ukrainians out
they took very heavy casualties in this
process and inflicted very heavy
casualties on the Ukrainian Army at the
same time and having finished this uh
they basically needed to go back away
from the front lines for rest and
recovery and you know to to to
replenish their losses retrain their
units and so on
um but in the background of all of this
one of the things that has been
happening is obviously pregozian and and
Wagner they are a unit that is
essentially or you could almost argue
independent of the Russian military and
this is a problem from the perspective
of the Russian Ministry of Defense uh
because it's not a unit that's under
their control and increasingly uh
precautions started criticizing very
publicly the Russian minister of defense
shoigu and the head of the general staff
gerasimov and so they've been in this
battle of words for many many months
precaution accused them of not providing
enough ammunition of using poor tactics
of being incompetent and all of this
stuff in public in Russia you know this
isn't like the UK where you can
criticize the head of the army or the
military and that's kind of people you
people give you a pat on the back for
that it's really completely unheard of
on Russia particularly from someone from
another branch of this fighting in the
same War
um and this conflict was amplifying and
amplifying and amplifying uh to the
point where precaution once did recorded
this video in front of like the corpses
of his soldiers saying these men have
died because of the incompetence of the
ministry of Defense screaming give me
ammunition give me blah blah blah blah
and so when they were pulling back
remember after I said after they took
Batman
they in this is according to precaution
anyway uh as they were as they were
moving back to positions in the rear uh
the road that they were using was mind
there were mines on the road in
territory controlled by Russia uh and
when they sent in disposal engine bone
disposal Engineers to deal with it they
came under Fire from the Russian side
and what they then did is they basically
responded to the fire uh encircled the
units that were firing on them and what
they found is there was a a unit of the
Russian military uh they arrested or
detect not arrested they detained the
colonel who was in charge of it beat him
up clearly tortured him whatever and put
them on camera
and he refused to say why he gave the
order to attack Ragnar he just said I
have a deep personal antipathy towards
you uh but you wouldn't explain who gave
him the order if anybody
um so then they they went back into the
rear uh after all of this so a lot of
people saw this as an escalation of the
conflict between the ministry of defense
and Wagner and yesterday uh pregotom
claimed that Russian military had
dropped bombs on his units
in Russian territory or
russian-controlled territory
and he was like okay this is enough we
are now going to uh deal with showing
the the defense minister and girasana of
the head of the basically a mutiny it
wasn't actually a cougar coup would be
him trying to take over the presidency
now that may be what was happening uh
but it was actually more he at least was
claiming what that what this was about
was uh throwing off the defense minister
and uh the head of the army although if
you think about it I mean if you're
President Putin and I'm the head of the
army and someone wants to overthrow me
you've appointed me so at the very very
least you're massively undermining my
authority anyway so they got the columns
together and they started basically
marching on Moscow
they captured a major city called roster
vondon and then they started going
towards Moscow avoiding major cities
avoiding firefights there were whole
units of Russian military soldiers who
laid down their arms and didn't want to
interfere in that fight and a few
minutes ago we heard from pregosian
himself that he basically said well the
reason we did this he's changed the
explanation uh the original explanation
was they attacked us then he said they
wanted to disband my unit they wanted to
disband Wagner so we went on what he
called the March for justice uh towards
Moscow they got to about
probably within about 150 to 200
kilometers so they'd already reached the
Moscow region and Moscow Obelisk is
called
um and they were basically heading there
and in the last few minutes uh they've
said that they're pulling back and going
back to to where they were stationed
now given that in the meantime what had
happened is the mayor of Moscow
suspended any movements in Moscow called
it a non-working day basically everybody
stay at home and Putin came went on TV
and said this is treason this is Mutiny
these people will be punished
etc etc etc
um this doesn't end here because if
you've taken up arms essentially against
your country particularly in Russia
um this is this is gonna uh it'll either
end very quickly if you know what I mean
or this will run in terms of its
repercussions I mean one of the things
obviously it shows is that Putin's
Authority is weakening it
um it doesn't mean he's not in charge uh
you know and people will say I'm being
biased against Putin I mean no an armed
Mutiny in Russia is a sign of the of the
fact that the president's Authority is
in question another thing that we should
say as well is uh percussion is not the
only one in essentially with a private
Army in Russia there's also ramzan of
the the leader of chechnya now he is
loyal to Putin at the moment but he
Ascend he has somewhere between 20 and
70 000 troops including reservists
depending how you count it who are loyal
entirely to him and while their formerly
judging is obviously part of the Russian
Federation
um
you know the the people who live there
are uh their own ethnicity they're
Muslim rather than Orthodox Christian
they have a very strong local identity
so in the event that things kick off I
mean there's my point is there's other
players that could get involved in this
situation and Putin has been building up
the National Guard under one of his
loyalists so there's several essentially
private armies in addition to the
ministry of defense that could
potentially in a situation like this
been vying for uh leadership and you
know the chechens for example they said
well we're going to go and stop
pregosity because they hate him in
Wagner for many reasons they've been in
the pissing match for for the last many
months
um okay well let's say the chechens get
to Moscow let's say they chase off
precaution well if Putin needs them
why do they need Putin right so this
this had the potential to be a very
dangerous situation and still does
because we don't know if it's actually
been resolved
um I mean privately I did say to you
this morning that I I did didn't think
this would end up in a you know in the
novice throughout the government or
anything uh it may do still nobody
really knows but that's kind of the
background to where we are and one of
the questions that I really want to ask
is I find it bizarre that somebody who
is as power hungry as Putin who is an
authoritarian
why does he have private armies working
for him well why doesn't he have the
Russian army uh because he can't fund
the Russian well one of the reasons I
explained to you which is he needed them
for operations yeah that he couldn't do
with the full weight of the Russian
State behind it so if you need someone
to go I mean the Americans had and I
don't know if you remember this Scandal
there was a scandal in Iraq when uh some
people from a company called Blackwater
they killed civilians uh in Iraq and
there was a big Scandal the guy had to
sell this company they changed the name
blah blah blah blah blah but but
basically a lot of big company uh big
countries around the world have been
experimenting with this model where you
have armed mercenaries that are acting
under your direct control but they're
not directly attributable to your to you
so for example
I'm not saying this is exactly why Putin
would have wanted it but remember at the
beginning I mentioned how
um so to to give you a very brief
rundown in Syria the Americans and the
Russians actually coordinated
their movement even though they were on
the opposite sides of that war uh
because Russia backed Assad and
obviously the Americans didn't but the
last thing they wanted was for like
Americans accidentally to be fighting
Russians and before you know in World
War III okay yeah so in this battle that
I told you about I wish I could remember
the name now
but I did a series of Tweets in which I
mentioned it
um today the the Americans said we're
about to engage this Syrian unit are
there any Russian soldiers attached to
it and the Russians were like No And The
Americans were cool so we'll take care
of it then and they killed somewhere I
think two between two and four hundred
Wagner mercenaries because the Russians
basically said well these are not our
guys right so that's obviously the
downside of plausible deniability of
these people being attached to the
Russian military but essentially what it
allows you to do is act in ways around
the world that you couldn't act as a
state because it would be too much of a
transgression for you to do so or there
would be too much bad press or bad
publicity so that's one reason the other
reason is
this is what I was saying to you is if
you have a bunch of various private
armies emerging in the country uh you're
not necessarily going to be able to rely
on the Russian military all right what
if the Russian military becomes
mutualist for some reason you want a a
force or a set of forces in Putin's case
uh that you control that you can use to
defend yourself to assert your Authority
and so on and progression was known as
Putin's Chef he was actually a guy who
owned restaurants like you've very
closely connected with Putin apparently
until recently so don't know what's
going on there and nobody does
um and the third thing is I mean this is
an elite unit they're much better
trained much more disciplined much
better equipped than the regular Russian
army are they better paid as well and
they're better paid yeah
because that was a that was one of the
criticisms with the Russian armies that
the pay was awful they weren't properly
trained they didn't have the right
ammunition they didn't have the but
terribly funded so that being the case
he's obviously got many legitimate
grievances against the Russian army
against the
the Russian government but this looks
like an act of lunacy doesn't it on his
behalf well I mean you say legitimate
nobody knows whether they're really
legitimate grievances uh because both I
mean this is also true of the Ukrainian
Army but the Russian army has had
problems with ammunition supplies uh and
all over the place it's so it's not like
necessarily they were being targeted
although they may have been some of that
going on as well so we don't know
whether his grievance is legitimate or
not but I mean obviously you cannot have
25 000 men marching on Moscow
uh and by the way this is unconfirmed
but I've heard a lot of very credible
reports that uh the column that was
heading towards Moscow was repeatedly
attacked by helicopters and several of
them were shot down really so they shot
allegedly we don't know for certain yet
but allegedly they shot down several
Russian army helicopters which are you
know to say nothing of the fact that
they killed Russian Ammon uh they also
shut down you know equipment worth tens
of millions of dollars so
the uh I mean obviously none of us knows
how this is going to go I would be very
surprised if he gets away with this and
was Putin's reaction been to this well
the only thing we know and this is the
thing for months as this slanging match
was going on between the mod the Russian
mod and Wagner he he hadn't said
anything and in fact in one of
priguration's statements where he was
talking about uh garasimov and shoigur
the defense minister and head of the
general staff uh he actually said
something about how well maybe Grandpa
has lost the plot
right and he then took it back and said
I wasn't really talking about Putin and
blah blah blah but he was starting to to
sort of um
get ahead of himself maybe is the right
phrase
but doesn't that show that Putin's that
this war has
destroyed Putin's credibility if you've
got people being openly mutinous yeah
people CR openly mocking Putin people
will openly criticizing the ministry of
Defense
I mean well you and I are both NATO
Shields so we would say that uh but
objectively speaking I do think it's
fair to say uh I say this with unbritish
understatement and sarcasm I think it is
fair to say that when you've got a large
military unit rising up and marching on
your own capital is probably fair to say
that you may have less control over the
of the armed forces in the country than
you had before yeah I think that's I
think and so has Putin not come out has
he made any kind of stuff he made one
statement so the only time that he's
commented on it was today when he
basically did a short seven minute video
in which he said these people are
traitors they're going to be punished I
call on on the Russian forces to you
know uh I I call on everybody to avoid
Bloodshed but these people will be dealt
with blah blah blah blah blah uh but the
fact that the the mayor of Moscow you
know basically put the city into
lockdown uh shows you that they weren't
messing around this was serious they
were they were very close they were
coming
um and yeah I mean it's a bit this is a
big problem for Putin and one of the
things that we're going to find out now
is you know these 25 000 mercenaries
they are loyal to pragosan they are
loyal to him there's he built this Cult
of you know looking after his soldiers
and and arguably he certainly does it a
lot better than Russian Generals in the
Army who are incompetent
ly uh so they're loyal to him uh and you
know if you take out progression what
are they going to do they might just be
like well okay we don't have a leader
anymore we gotta yeah we gotta quit or
they might really Rebel you don't know
uh but on the other hand for Putin I
mean he he has to do something and I
would I mean I will tell you honestly if
I were him I would have progression
arrested and executed that's what you
have to do if you want to stay in power
that's what would happen
um so it just remains to be seen how
this one plays out but can he actually
arrest precaution if if he is good this
crap
elite team of over 20 000 men who
marched on Russia marched on Moscow shot
down helicopters allegedly allegedly
right allegedly yeah
how's he going to arrest him
well that remains to be seen I mean one
of the obvious ways you do it is you fly
them in somewhere for negotiations or
you know whatever whether that would
work or not but you've got to understand
this is not a sustainable situation no
right you can't have that I mean you we
couldn't have that at trigonometry to
people being like you know what we're
going to sabotage everything you guys
are doing like we wouldn't tolerate that
you can't tolerate this particularly
when it's armed Mutiny uh and you can't
give people let people get away with it
one of the reasons is it encourages
other people to do it yeah and so what's
up what effect has that had on the war
with the Ukraine well so if this had
carried on the effect would have been is
obviously it probably would have first
of all it's a massive distraction so
that means the ukrainians would have the
opportunity to do things but also if it
really carried on I mean some of all of
Russia's combat ready units are
essentially in Ukraine or on the border
with Ukraine getting ready to get
involved so they would have to pull some
of them back and that obviously opens up
gaps the Ukrainian counteroffensive
hasn't really gone very well at all they
haven't committed the majority of their
troops yet to the counter-offensive that
everyone's been talking about but the
efforts they have made which has kind of
been more reconnaissance and force than
actual full-scale
attacks haven't gone well at all so this
may have been the opportunity the
ukrainians needed the the fact that it's
been shut down within the space of a day
means that the ukrainians haven't had
the the opportunity to really take
advantage of this so far has been know
but the average Russian must look at
Putin now and he must be diminished in
their eyes significantly so the one
thing you should know about Russia is
um is actually I met somebody uh that
when I was in America who helped Boris
yelton design his campaign slogans and
he said we did all the polling and the
campaign slogan we came up with was
strong leader for a strong Russia that's
the mentality yeah uh the moment you're
not a strong leader
you know people I'm not saying it's over
I'm not saying people are going to rise
up and throw overthrow you but yeah you
lose a lot of credibility this is not
done putting any good at all which is
why I suspect he may end up doing
something very harsh in response do you
think that what we're seeing and the
predictions are always terrible and in
many ways probably not the fairest of
questions do you think we're seeing the
the beginning of the end for Vladimir
Putin here no I certainly wouldn't want
to say that and I actually don't think
neces no I wouldn't want to say either
way because I just don't think we know
really I don't I I think there is no
evidence right now to suggest it's the
beginning of the end it could be but it
may well look if he comes out tomorrow
you know a respiration uh has him
executed or whatever
um you know maybe makes changes in terms
of the way the Army is managed and all
of this other stuff uh he may well be
able to to recover his situation and
actually come back from the stronger
that's also a possibility uh or may go
the other way we genuinely don't know
and how is Prague seen in Russia is he
seen as a hero somebody who depends by
him it's like saying you know how is
Donald Trump seen in America well half
the country thinks he's a legend and
half the country hates him yeah you know
with precaution it's it's very difficult
to say what on balance people think
about him uh one of the things that he
has achieved is because his unit has
been
one of the very few that has actually
done well in the fighting uh that has
made forward progress where other units
have failed and stalled Etc and he's
been very good at building up and
cultivating this image of this
successful military leader even though
he's actually a commander at all uh he's
kind of more like the pr head of the
unit
um he has cultivated this sense of like
being a strong leader and being
successful and being one of the few
people we Russians can rely on to to go
and win in Ukraine
um so from that perspective there will
certainly be people who like him there
will obviously be people who are not
happy because you know he is organizing
an armed Mutiny in the middle of a war
that Russia while not overwhelmingly you
know the Russian perspective of what's
happening in Ukraine is it's it's you
know we're not losing but we're not
winning either which is not what we were
told would happen we were told you know
our tanks will roll into Kiev very
quickly this is an easy thing this is
more of a military operation it's now a
full-blown war in which Russia has had
to give seed territory that it's taken
over significant chunks of territory
including there in your harkib in the
north they are near Kiev in the center
they are near Hassan and Hassan itself
in the South which Russia had to abandon
so in Russia you know the war is seen as
not going great and there's a very sort
of TV propagandists who who are very
bullish at the beginning they're now all
talking about you know why isn't it
going as well as it could well it's the
evil NATO giving them weapons and blah
blah blah blah so that's the tone of the
conversation so against that backdrop
progression is one of the few successful
military commanders as people would see
him uh in the conflict he gets a lot of
credibility yeah and do you think
because Russia is one of those countries
that is very large and there's a very
credible argument that could be made
that you need a strong man like Putin in
order to hold this enormous country
together otherwise it simply won't work
do you think there are people like the
chechens looking at this and going
this may be our moment to have a go I I
think the chechens at this moment based
on what I've seen are loyal to Putin
doesn't mean that they are permanently
loyal to Putin but they clearly haven't
seen this as a uh as their moment to
jump yeah
um at the moment we just remains to be
seen you've got to remember this is
um a lot of people have actually been
predicting this would happen oh really
yeah well one of them is a guy called
the Igor strokov who is actually one of
the uh paramilitaries who fought for the
rebels in 2014 he's uh very
anti-ukrainian he says Ukraine shouldn't
exist blah blah blah blah blah but what
he's what there's a growing actually
movement in Russia of people who are
anti-putin because they see him as weak
who are anti the military because they
see them as weak they don't see them as
hard enough they don't see them as you
know they say we need a full
mobilization we they say we need to call
it a war we need to put Russia on a
wartime footing and what they've been
talking about and this is
uh you know one of the reasons that
people in Russia crave a strong leader
is Russian history I've talked about
this to a few people privately
um so there's a time in Russian history
called times of trouble in Russia we
call it and what happened was uh this is
uh the period of Ivan the Terrible uh
who if you remember he he's known really
for two things he uh well he was he
expanded Russia uh or what what it was
at the time but what he also did is he
he killed his Elder son in a fit of rage
and his next son who was very weak and
probably you know mentally disabled and
essentially he ended up with no air
and the times of trouble is the period
after that during which there is like
half the population dies in famine uh
the polls invade the lithuanians invade
there's a series of false Pretenders to
the throne that get overthrown and the
whole land basically is ravished
by one ill after another for decades on
decades on decades a terrible time in
Russian history and what Russians learn
and this is something that we learn in
school that from a young age what
Russians learned in that time is when
you don't have a strong leader bad
things happen terrible terrible terrible
things happen and the reason that people
have been predicting that this sort of
thing would start to happen is it's
actually what happened in 1917 in the
Russian Revolution because Russia was
fighting in World War one uh all of the
combat ready units were on the front
lines whereas in the rear there was a
lot of social Discord and social
instability which was then used to
destabilize the Army uh and you ended up
with the government being overthrown and
the regime change that happened so
people have been saying like we're
heading towards smuta uh and that's
always the big fear in Russia so uh the
the difference is that uh a lot of
people thought that water would take is
for a big setback in Ukraine uh to
happen before people started having a go
if you like so percussion may have
jumped the gunhead yeah indeed he he
might I find it very interesting because
obviously I read British Publications
and my Russian isn't that good but one
of those good is it
well not the best mate but one of the
things that I find actually deeply
unhelpful is when people look at Russia
through a British or a European lens and
it's it's not helpful because
I don't think people understand this
they perceive the world in a very
different way so take the example of
democracy with Boris Yeltsin explain to
us what does democracy for example mean
to a Russian well so I've said this many
times Russia has never had democracy
yeah uh and the unexperienced Russia had
with democracy was the period between
1991 when Boris Yeltsin comes to power
the Soviet Union collapses and and 1999
uh When Vladimir Putin comes to power
yeah in which point you know you have
elections but you don't have democracy
because you know elections aren't
democracy democracy is the ability to
change uh who leads your country by the
part of the people if you clean out all
your potential opponents
rig elections to some extent Etc it's
not a it's not a democracy
and Russian people don't want it uh you
know when I say that people think I'm
sort of slagging enough Russian people
don't want democracy because the only
experience of democracy is eight years
in which you had inflation at points of
84 was probably the same we've got here
at the moment mate yeah
um you know a financial crisis uh you
had a situation where Chechen terrorists
drove into Russia I mean this is going
to sound quite familiar to what's
happening now but they drove into Russia
in into uh buses
um see captured a hospital
in in one of the bordering towns heard
that about a thousand people in there
um heldham hostage killed some of them
and they essentially got the Russian
state to negotiate with them and give
them concessions
that's how embarrassing that was imagine
you you were the Soviet Union the the
one of the two superpowers in the world
and now you're negotiating with some
church and warlord wow right so that was
humiliating you had terrorist attacks
you had
uh incredible instability in terms of
employment and jobs and that we've
talked about this before but people who
uh you know you could have been a
respect respectable scientist yesterday
and today you're selling your belongings
in the street and the people who
actually are in charge of your country
now uh are criminals who've seized
control of the the public assets and
they're selling them off and they're
driving around in Mercedes and limos
while you're starving uh you know there
were two Wars in chechnya et cetera Etc
so it was a terrible period of chaos for
Russians uh and if that's what you
thought democracy meant why would you
want it absolutely and looking at what
happened at the collapse of the Soviet
Union many people didn't predict that it
was going to end so quickly and a lot of
people say it's because we didn't really
understand what was going on in the
Soviet Union and obviously the policy of
secrecy Etc do you think that's the case
now that actually that it could be
nearer the end than we think because we
simply don't know enough about what's
going on in Russia well I don't think
it's that we don't know enough about
what's going to Russia although I think
that's certainly true I think it's more
that we can't predict the future even if
we know a lot about what's going on
Russia right uh I mean look at the last
few years in this country or the West
have we been able to predict much of of
what's going on there Anton by the way
I'm just worried that if we've got like
loads of super chats building up we may
and and questions on locals as well
which if you are a local supporter make
sure you head over there because we'll
do those questions first yeah I'm just
wary of are we going to have enough time
to handle all of them so just give us a
shout when you think yeah
so if you've got questions guys send
them in either on locals or in the Super
Chat here okay so there have been also a
lot of people in the British press some
very educated people may say who are
celebrating this fact and going this is
the end of Putin this is brilliant
excellent stuff
yeah I mean I think that's unwise why
well Russia
has a lot of nuclear weapons okay and
Chaos in a nuclear state is not
necessarily a good thing again to say
with some British understatement I mean
I don't think we I mean uh ramzan
khadirov doesn't strike me as a
particularly responsible leader so if he
was to get involved and end up in
control of one of the largest nuclear
can you just clarify who is that he's
the leader of church
I mean who knows how sensible he is I
don't think he's
he's as crazy and he seems quite a smart
operator but my point is you don't want
people in nuclear country fighting over
the the the nuclear suitcase the nuclear
launch codes you know what I mean you
don't want armed struggle over that not
least because you don't know exactly you
know who's going to control which Silo
at what time who's going to use it
against who right because if you are you
know at some kind of warlord and your
life's on the line well maybe you know
maybe this is a card that you're going
to use in one way or another
um so I I think that I I very much
understand until a large extent share
people's animosity towards Putin
particularly after the invasion of
Ukraine and in which the Russian forces
have done some awful awful things and
The Invasion itself is obviously awful
um but I don't necessarily think that uh
encouraging cares on Russia is a great
thing you mentioned earlier about you
know Russia disintegrating I'm not
convinced that that I mean look Russia
disintegrating would not be a good thing
yeah I'm also not necessarily convinced
that there's that many parts of Russia
that would want to split off I mean
you're looking at church near Dagestan
probably about it to be honest I mean
Belarus would fall away and and be kind
of less under Russia's control but I
don't see like individual Russian
regions being like yeah we've got a
national identity we want to split off
but nonetheless chaos in a country like
that and a power struggle in a country
like that is probably not what anybody
wants so what do you think
how are the US and the UK and the West
going to be looking at this so would
they see it as a positive move or is no
I don't think they would I think we just
talked about it I think the instability
in a nuclear country is their number one
issue yeah because that's you know if
that goes in a bad way
but that's a potentially terrible
situation like potentially ending all
life on Earth situation yeah
um
so I think that would be the first
concern is how do you make sure there's
security and stability for that and then
beyond that I mean who knows exactly
what they're thinking I do think they
they'd like to get rid of Putin but the
and I've talked about this before you
know I keep making this point to people
you know when when the conflict first
erupted or when Russia first invaded
Ukraine people like well why don't we
just take out Putin and I'm like well
who do you think is going to come to
power when you do that Nick Clegg is
waiting in the wings you know what I
mean yeah it's not really like that so
um I think the forces that are currently
vying for power on Russia I I actually
not necessarily all that much better
than Putin so I think from from a
western perspective you just have to be
careful on where and see so the forces
are vying for but is there somebody who
is seen as a legitimate alternative to
Putin no and the reason for that is is
you spend the last so he came to power
in 1999 he spent the last 24 years
making sure there was no one so if you
were somebody of a different mindset to
him who wanted to challenge what he was
doing you were like you were either
exiled poisoned or put in prison that
happened to literally everybody who at
any point attempted to organize the
resistance of any kind to his even
politically so whether that's Gary
Kasparov Mikhail cassianov Miguel
korokovsky
um
navalny of course Alexia navalny uh all
of them have very quickly found
themselves one in one of those in one of
those categories exiled poisoned or
imprisoned uh so there isn't anybody uh
other than these Warlords essentially uh
who who are now vying for power on
Russia wow so at the moment we really
don't know what is going to be happening
and it's
and I was going to suggest do you want
to maybe read a few of the locals
comments and okay because we would have
we've got them and in the meantime it
gives me a chance to just catch up and
see what else is going on so I can
update people as well
see you on your phone now okay so please
remember to send in your Super Chat send
in your questions sending your paypals
and if you join locals that means that
we will look at your questions first by
the way Francis would you like to know
how many people are watching how many 10
000 people
wow so thank you for tuning in all 10
000 of you right uh Anton please send
them through to me and then we can have
Earth yeah so first one is from Sheila
Powell what I want to know is who are
these people who is funding them how
does this affect Ukraine well I think
we've covered mostly most of that the
interesting question in there Sheila is
who is funding them because up until
this point it was very clear that
pragosian and Wagner were funded by
Putin yeah one way or another but in
this instance it would seem yeah like
he's got support and there may be some
kind of Shadow player behind the scenes
who's orchestrating all of this and that
really is the interesting thing to
explore I know that a lot of you know
conspiracy people because it's the CIA
it's not the CIA I don't think so uh Jim
White's a very good question does Prague
ocean have proper allies in Moscow he
will do yeah yeah well and and so
recently Putin was one of them so this
doesn't make a lot of sense uh Darius
says what were the different what were
the different military organizations in
Russia do I.E the FSB the National Guard
Etc and how many organizations are there
well there's loads the FSB is the
successor to the KGB so they're the the
secret police basically
um the the National Guard their job is
Riot and protest suppression and then
you've got all kinds of other special
units for you know rapid response to
this policing Etc
uh crash car star says would you make of
the latest reports of Belarusian
president uh lukashenko has just held
talks about bregortion and the advance
toward Moscow is now halted well we
talked about this right at the beginning
so the advance towards now towards
Moscow is halted uh because precaution
has come out and said it's halted
whether uh lukashenka had anything to do
with that I don't know earlier I read
the precaution uh said that they held
talks but nothing came of it yeah so we
don't know why exactly they decided to
pull back uh the Laurier sauce hasn't
Putin just successfully flushed out all
the disloyal elements in his military no
uh no that he hasn't at all uh the
precaution has been the head of it and
Wagner has been open about it uh but I
know he hasn't uh and I I think actually
uh what you'll probably find is unless
he is very very harsh with with this
Mutiny he will have created more uh
potential mutinies in the future uh
Eliza bucket hello Eliza uh is
precaution mad or so does he have
support in high places which we've
already covered but let's talk about him
as a character what do we know about his
character well he's very outspoken he's
very controversial he's basically like
me if I had an army man no I mean he
he's uh he he he he does his business in
public
um and is he mad I mean look if you look
at history history is always made by
people making crazy moves 99 of them end
up dead yeah right the one percent
actually end up succeeding so there is a
very long and storied history of people
attempting to overthrow governments and
failing which is what he's what he's
done here okay so Norfolk boy says the
1991 coup against Gorbachev came from
inside the government and it led to the
end of the Communist party but then they
had Boris Yeltsin is a situation now
similar and if not why not well one of
the things that Gorbachev failed to do
is really crack down he didn't want to
spill blood and that's why they
essentially broke up the Soviet Union uh
whether Putin is of the same mindset I
don't think so no and so I look nobody
knows he's getting old nobody you know
there's rumors about his health blah
blah blah blah nobody knows the truth I
would be I mean it's possible but I
would be surprised if if the pushback on
this is not very harsh well it has to be
doesn't it because otherwise she doesn't
I mean it's hard to see how he survives
this right yeah uh so gab the chef uh
says this move from Wagner looks very ad
hoc and regardless of the personal
losses is there a possibility that money
is also playing a role here after all
they're soldiers for hire
uh you know it's interesting because
they are sold Just For Hire but one of
the things that's very clear is they
have very high internal unit morale like
they're all backing him and they have
done throughout the conflict so I think
one way or another he somehow created
some kind of ideological Unity within
his organization where he has a he
enjoys a lot of personal loyalty uh from
from his troops well I mean that makes
uh it's definitely not about money yeah
it's definitely like I mean if he stops
paying them I think some some loyalty
might be lost but but it they're not
doing this for money right I mean it
makes sense because if you think about
it to a lot of these guys pregosian gave
them a second chance if you've got if
you've been sentenced to 20 years in a
Russian jail I mean there's no
guarantees you're going to make it out
of that and if you do you're not going
to come out better and also they're
well-fed well-trained well equipped
well-armed they get you know he goes out
and advocates for them whereas a lot of
Russian conscripts get thrown into the
meat grinder with very little uh they
get treated very badly they have leaders
that don't give a about them this
is what they say yeah when you read the
report so
um from that perspective I mean someone
who actually looks after you and wants
you to survive a war you'd sort of feel
like they're on your team you know what
I mean and I think that would probably
engender a lot of personal loyalty yeah
and obviously a a unit that has a lot of
personal loyalty that has a shared
valued share ideals shared ideals and
respects and loves their leader which
they appear to do yeah I mean and
they're going up against a military who
are divided who
don't believe probably and have a lost a
lot of faith in what they're doing I
mean you're looking at it and going
there's only going to be one winner
surely
I mean that is worrying for Putin
um so Anton if you can send us uh some
super chats through please and we can
start looking at it but these are the
questions that you had
that's all the locals questions that's
the locals questions well uh guys head
on over to locals if you're a local
supporter and ask your questions there
if you want them to be asked as a
priority but in the meantime we can do
some super chats as well yeah Anton are
you going to put them up on the screen
yeah put them on the screen for
everybody well let's try I don't know if
I'll be able to see so maybe I will log
into yeah yeah Francis can log into the
stream so this is from Nathan Woodard
that much I can see yeah and he so
Nathan Woodard hello brother hope you're
good uh he said his 360 uh 69.69 for the
greatest show on Earth I've uh I've just
got two rack of ribs for
2.99 pounds for uh and I'm passing the
savings on to you I tried to buy some
Russian dressing uh for my side salad
but they don't sell it here anymore so I
made it from scratch keep it up and stay
home well Nathan can I just say I'm so
terribly sorry the war is really really
affected you this badly it's terrible
obviously we can all agree on that okay
so uh let's go to we have got uh AI with
uh who has asked the question why did
Putin oh so I think it says out why did
Putin not see this coming and act faster
I don't know I genuinely don't know one
of the things if you remember we talked
about it is like he has ref at least
publicly said nothing about it and
clearly not not cracked down on it
privately either yeah so we've got to a
situation where he's basically allowed
this to happen by it's like you've got
you're a teacher so you watch two kids
fighting and you don't get involved
eventually it's going to escalate yeah
and now like one of them is turned
around and started running at the
teacher yeah basically and because he
didn't get involved at the time so who
knows why but the question Russians will
be asking is has he lost his power has
he lost the authority has he lost the
ability to get people to calm down and
focus on the objective which for Russia
is winning the war so you could argue
that in the sense this entire problem
stems from Putin's weakness in order to
not dealing with progression like he
should have done well you could argue
that but we obviously don't know what's
going on behind the scenes right like we
have no idea why he's chosen to make the
decisions that he made so is it weakness
or is there some other thing going on
that remains to be seen and I guess
we'll see that uh when when the response
to this happens this is the the real
interesting thing here is how does Putin
deal with this uh because on the one
hand he has to assert his authority on
the other hand you made the point you
know how do you deal with someone who's
got an army of 25 5 000 very well-armed
men I suppose the way you deal with it
is
you know to what happened yesterday and
today is they started marching on Moscow
and the Russian military was under
underprepared but the Russian military
is much bigger than Wagner yeah so if
they concentrated all their efforts on
dealing with that they probably could
put them in a position where they could
either get slaughtered uh or Surrender
and at that point I suppose a lot of
them would surrender but it's also as
well can they really do that when
they're fighting a war on the other
front which makes us very interesting
about Ukraine because one of the
potential plays for Putin here is look
we've conquered some territory in
Ukraine
um actually more than we said we were
trying to yeah uh We've inflicted heavy
casualties on the ukrainians I mean
forget about Russian casualties for a
moment but we've done that we've made it
clear to Nato and the West that we're
not messing about here we need to be
taken seriously let's negotiate some
kind of settlement where we get some
land I can walk if I'm Putin I can walk
away with that egg on my face and I can
deal with this stuff internally and make
sure that I'm I'm fully in control of
the country that is a potential outcome
of this and in my opinion that would be
the best outcome here for everybody so
this is from uh Buca says and they say
do you guys think that flip uh of six
billion dollars from Pentagon for war in
Ukraine may be laid down on Wagner
account wink wink so this is the CIA
question yeah I mean that's ridiculous
so there we go loads of people were
saying this online before even uh any
information to come out because some
people like to think that the Americans
are behind everything and the CIA is
behind everything
um but
um yeah I'm really not convinced okay so
estral cab you chaos if another bout of
anti-luca shenko protest broke out in
Belarus would Putin have spare capacity
to crush them
um I think he probably would I also
think Belarus probably has the capacity
to cross them not least because in a war
situation I think there would be a lot
less restrained in the way that they
crushed them yeah I think I think a
protest now would get put down
very very brutally okay Harry Palms uh
says if our species is to move forward
we need to put war and armed conflict
behind us love the show it's always nice
to have people who smoke weed watching
the show
uh I mean who can disagree with that
yeah that is true but then you know
we've talked about this before in the
context of War I mean it's it's a
terrible thing to say but it is true
and we are bands of chimps yeah and
chimps go to war yeah and that's what we
are
um and
it you know if you look at human history
I mean you travel to any country you
look at The Monuments you look at the
the museums what are they all about
trance
[Laughter]
who can take Putin's place
uh well we've talked about this already
yeah
um so we really don't know actually
what's interesting is the defense
minister shoigu he was mooted as being a
potential replacement uh but he's been
very badly discredited for from by this
war so right now it's very very
difficult to see any clear and obvious
candidate uh Putin has been grooming a
lot of younger uh potential Future
Leaders they have some kind of
Leadership Institute and blah blah blah
blah blah but right now I I don't see it
but then again In fairness to Putin uh
when he was promoted to be prime
minister and then was essentially given
the presidency uh nobody had heard of
him either so who knows so yes sir there
is that Traditions isn't there in Russia
of people coming from nowhere tradition
is probably overstating it but but yeah
yeah it has happened it has happened
indeed uh Joseph Yasin has asked a
question that is absolutely ridiculous
referencing not only Prince Prince Harry
and Megan but also Dylan Mulvaney but
also we're not gonna it's not raw Joseph
it's good to know people are paying uh
paying attention and really appreciating
the sense of the moment yeah absolutely
and taking it seriously okay so Laura
smart has also sent me through some
super chat so we in case that we've got
questions or yeah uh super uh so they
are super chats at the moment so let's
just get these I need to log in
for 10 bucks in the meantime says Dylan
Mulvaney should be next Russian
president
Mulvaney should be next Russian I'm not
your buddy guy with the five Canadian
dollar says can you imagine the egg on
she's face when trying to convince
people to switch off the petrodollar to
their brick stability well this is you
know a lot of people who hate the West
including people in the west they like
to talk about how you know the West is
over and everybody's switching to this
and that and the dealer dollarization I
mean he is a Potential Threat but you've
got to I think people always massively
overestimated the ability
of the Russian state to really
effectively challenge uh challenge the
American dominance yeah in my opinion so
uh okay
um so it says uh I'm not uh
so if we read that I'm not your buddy
guy yeah I've just read that one yeah
that was that one okay Hobie Hamilton
says uh Putin just uh interviewed and
when he asked about progression he said
get the belt thanks Colby uh the master
of Tricks says uh could Medvedev take
over or is he very much out so Edward of
Medvedev has been out of the team for a
long time
um he's not really taken seriously he
had a shot at the presidency for one
term uh he wasn't viewed as a strong
leader uh and he still has a role uh and
he's been given various prominent roles
but he hasn't been taken seriously for a
long time everybody jokes about being
him being an alcoholic
um some of the stuff that he's been
saying has seemed quite the range lately
so yeah I I don't think he's a credible
alternative at all okay so uh David Cott
asks a question uh
essentially asking about what is the
outcome uh you you going to for all of
us to be and uh and again what do you
think of a progression stopping before
Moscow I mean
it looks it looks rash to put it mildly
to stop or to go well to go and then to
stop well actually you make a very good
point and I've been thinking about this
right yeah if you make that play yeah
and then you stop
what's the best scenario I mean you're
the very very very least going to prison
surely yeah he can't be he can't believe
that he's just going to get away with
this can he
but will this I mean you wonder what it
was he must it must be an emotional
reaction it can't have been that he
thought about this logically
well look his play was you know I'm
gonna go on Moscow and I'm gonna get
what I want right yep
now if you make that play you they're
only I mean as far as I can see there
are only two outcomes there right yeah
either you win or you lose what he's
done now is he's aborted the play and
he's still going to lose I mean kutson
has said on National Television the
people who have done this are going to
be punished forgotten is the face of
this thing
what Putin's not going to punish him now
I mean I don't see that I I could be
wrong no one can predict the future
I don't see that and if Putin does that
then his presidency is really on the way
you know that might well be the
beginning of the end then yeah so I mean
that is an existential crisis for him
well that that is the end like he said
Jamie keeps okay that's actually a very
good question he says Constantine when
you say Russians don't want democracy
does that include their Millennials and
gen Z who are becoming increasingly
liberal they are becoming increasingly
liberal it's a good question James but
more than half of even young people in
Russia support Putin or did at least
until recently
um so I mean look young people in any
country are always going to be you know
anti The Establishment to some extent
and whatever it doesn't mean that by the
time they grow up to be 40 they don't
change their opinion
um so uh it really depends I people in
Russia don't really understand what
democracy is and so how can they want
something they've never really
experienced properly I think
if let's say Russia was to win the war
in Ukraine put them to stabilize the
country the economy was booming as it
was you know during the period over
which Putin really gained a lot of his
popularity and support uh I think Young
Russians would be very happy very happy
and comfortable with him the issue now
is he's not doing as well there's a
mutiny against him uh the war in Ukraine
is going badly the economy is not going
well he's invited all these sanctions
upon Russia which are affecting young
people in particular up to things silly
things like they can't buy video games
on Steam you know all the way through to
bigger issues that they're having so of
course this would have affected his
popularity with the people who already
didn't like him uh but you've got to
remember a lot of the people fighting
and dying for Russia in Ukraine are
young Russians uh some of whom really
believe in all of this stuff so
um I think I think the majority of
Russians still don't want democracy uh
they may want to change a leader though
or they may want a change of the regime
at some point depending on how this
plays out over time fincy says is there
ever a world where the Western Russia
can get along in other words is there
ever a world where the ideals of the
West can coexist with Russian ideals
um
well it's a long I mean it depends what
time period you're looking at I mean if
you're looking over a thousand years if
we're all still here who knows
um in the immediate term I don't think
so I mean Russia has moved since the 90s
in a much more anti-western direction oh
he's not even well part of it is
definitely anti-western but part of it
is it's you know it's Central you know
Putin always talks about this Russia he
argues and many people in Russia would
argue is its own civilization and so you
know are the Indians and the Chinese
ever going to get along well their
neighbors are probably not yeah you know
what I mean the two neighboring
civilizations and the you know the west
and why do we call it the West it's
because it's the successor to Western or
the Western Roman Empire yeah
um the East Russia sees itself as the
successor to the Byzantine Empire the
Eastern Roman Empire uh and they you
know that split happened over history
for a reason and these kids societies
have very different values uh they look
at the world in a very different way
they look at a religion they have
different ways of looking at religion
they have different ways of looking at
the the role of the individual the value
of human life you know all sorts of
different things now whether there's
going to be a convergence I mean right
now it's kind of hard to see yeah Amy
Val says do you have any idea of who
Putin would want to replace him when he
dies or gets taken out so does he have a
successor uh or do you think he doesn't
care about what happens when he's gone
no Putin 100 cares about what happens
when he's gone he sees himself as a
steward of Russia and a huge historical
figure which by the way even if as a
critical face you have to say he
undeniably is he's been in power for 24
years he's changed Russia in dramatic
and profound ways he certainly made it
stronger at least until recently
um and so he wants to hand that on and
for someone else to Steward Steward the
nation into the future he has been as I
said building up younger leaders in
different institutions and organizations
and whatever trying to bring different
people through he is looking for a
successor
right now it's hard to see who that is
okay so Nathan asked Nathan Woodard asks
uh can you imagine and describe a
plausible and bright future for Russia
moving forward from this moment in
history
well bright is a subjective word right I
mean there are a lot of people in Russia
whose subjective brightness would be the
they take over all of Ukraine uh find
some way to get NATO to give up the
baltics and Poland and Hungary and the
Czech Republic and Russia in Terror in
integrates them into its Fair influence
to a lot of people in Russia that would
be a very very bright future yeah so it
really really depends on what you mean
by a bright future from my perspective
um
I think the big misunderstanding between
Russia and the West is Russia believes
that everything the West does is
designed to punish and impede Russia's
expansion and development and that is
true to the extent that the West doesn't
want Russia expanding militarily into
into areas that are not currently within
its fear of influence but you know the
ordinary Russians understanding of what
people in the west want like this idea
that people in London are walking around
desperate to pin Russia in it's most
people in the west as you well know
don't care about Russia yeah most of
them even though it's very big couldn't
find it on the map right it's not the
the the ambition of the the Western
powers to to to Really attack Russia or
take really aggressive actions against
it and because of that misunderstanding
I think we're both mutually suspicious
of each other so if there is a way
to bring us back from that Brink and to
get people on both countries to
understand that despite the current
tensions actually Russians I mean Russia
feels like its security is is better
ensured by being bigger
um but Russia isn't a country that's you
know trying to take over the world I
mean under Putin it sometimes feels like
that or Russian people certainly don't
want that and likewise in the west we
don't really want that either so can you
get to a point where we got to actually
towards the end of the Soviet Union
where there was a lot more Mutual trust
than there was that to me would be the
brightest outcome for the whole world
for people in both countries to be
represented by leaders who are actually
trying to strike the right balance
between healthy competition and
collaboration and by the way
I mean if you look at if you look at it
in terms of resources you know Russia
has a lot of the stuff that we need and
we have all the stuff the Russian needs
you know they have the grain the wheat
the fertilizer the oil the gas the
Timber and we have technology and all of
that other stuff and if that trade could
be done in a way that these
conflicts didn't happen I think that
would be a really bright outcome but
what that requires is a little bit of
flex on both sides yeah uh so survey
Mike own local says the BBC reported
Putin inverted commas fled uh to Saint
Petersburg this seems very unputin like
I thought no this seems very Putin like
he's got bunkers all over the country
Saint Petersburg is where he's from
where his power base is uh and if if
troops are Marching on Moscow you don't
necessarily want to be there now we
don't know if it's true I haven't read
any confirmed reports of that's happened
I read some unconfirmed reports that's
happened uh but we don't know if that's
true yeah but it's not it's totally not
out of the Realms of the possible yeah
okay
so uh
bociani says did Wagner theoretically
have the forces and Hardware to
realistically take on Moscow today or
was this always some kind of
attention-seeking gesture we've returned
to base part of the pan all along I
don't think so and the reason I think
they were a genuine threat is this
Wagner is one of the best trained best
equipped best funded most experienced
units in the Russian in the entire
Russian Armed Forces uh Moscow doesn't
have 25
000 soldiers of equivalent equivalent
strength uh defending it right they've
got some national Guardsmen you know but
they don't have proper combat ready
troops and by the way people go you know
uh precaution these columns will just
get attacked Wagner has its own arm uh
Air Force they have helicopters they
have planes they have tanks they have
anti-aircraft missiles and anti-aircraft
systems they have the it's a it's an
army it's not just like some guys with
with rifles
um so yeah I mean they I personally in
my sense was that they were a genuine
threat and I didn't I don't think this
was part of the plan not least because
as I say uh I would be extraordinarily
surprised if
um if if precaution doesn't end up being
punished for this very severely I mean
well he has to be so this is from
Jonathan King Super Chat 10 pound if
Putin is ousted and it creates a power
vacuum do you think Western Nations
could be drawn into a civil Conflict by
proxy or otherwise to ensure a stable
nuclear power
we talked about this earlier I mean in
that situation
um someone's going to have to get
control of the nuclear launch codes
right and
um yeah that would not be a good
scenario
yep indeed
um
I mean it's kind of like you know they
parachute in Gary Kasparov uh back in
militarily and let him take control uh
not a good outcome uh so this is from
the charmingly named dog face Pepe
Soldier and he says if I were all cool
correctly and I meant I might not be
Khrushchev wasn't taken very seriously
until he was
yeah I mean look in Russia the way it
works is once you become leader people
take you seriously yeah right
um they have to you know it's it's a
Zara system really that in Russia people
uh this is perhaps a kind of putting two
final point on it but if you're a leader
you're sort of seen as anointed by God
to be leader and if you're a bad leader
well we just have to endure you and if
you're a good leader that's great we got
lucky it's kind of like that so once you
become a leader uh people will tolerate
you one way or another for you know
Russians have a lot of patience with
their leaders not even if they don't
like them and don't agree with them uh
trust no one says can Russia ever stop
seizing other people's territory by
force can they and never be content with
what they already have
well I I'd say it's a somewhat loaded
question but yeah um look from it what
Joseph Stalin wanted to do in World War
II and prior to World War II is you know
the Soviet Union was very clear it
sought hegemony of the European
continent
um from a Russian perspective they would
like to have what the what the Americans
have in the United States which is
complete control over their continent
right so the United States controls the
United States Canada is obviously a
friendly neighbor and Mexico is you know
gonna do what the Americans want them to
do yeah you know in terms of geopolitics
right so they have complete control of
their continent the problem for Russia
as Russia would see it geopolitically is
they they have to they have a bunch of
countries on their border that are not
only hostile to them but are backed by
the world superpower so from a Russian
perspective Russian security looks like
Russia having strong alliances or
neutrality from
um from Vladivostok to to Paris
basically or to the to the English
Channel at the very least
um and I I have a couple of pieces on my
sub stack about Alexander Dugan who's a
Russian philosopher uh talking about
this very thing that for Russia to be
secure Russia needs hegemony of Eurasia
there's a movement in Russia called
neo-euragianist and this is really what
they're talking about
right so I suppose the answer to the
question is probably not yeah baby blue
sky says uh Western media focusing on
Russian what is Ukraine's next move all
possibly what could their next move be
well as as we talked about earlier right
if if uh if this if this is over now it
doesn't really change the situation on
the ground in Ukraine other than maybe
if Putin punishes precaution then he's
lost one of his most effective units but
it doesn't change the the entire
conflict uh too much if this goes on and
on and there's a real power struggle and
they're having to pull troops from the
you know if troops are demoralized and
they're like well why are we fighting
when they're fighting behind us there's
no United rear behind us uh then it
gives Ukraine an opportunity to mount
the counter-offensive that they've been
trying to mount uh doink what a name
says is it possible that progression and
by extension Wagner defects is there any
way to escape punishment now that
they've stopped the Mutiny defects to
whom to Ukraine well the fact that I
would imagine the West is what they're
implying
no I don't think so yeah
um
whether he can avoid punishment you know
you and I have been talking about it for
the last hour and a bit yeah uh but no
there's no one he can defect too I mean
he's I I can't see you know Russian
soldiers who've been talking about
defending Russia this entire time going
and fighting for Ukraine no I don't see
that happening right so uh this is from
SEK 50 oh sorry free trade my apology
says I can hear the pro-russian factions
of the western right wing back peddling
already we never supported Putin epic
gaslighting well I actually think what
will happen is both sides in the debate
are going to say the same thing yeah
which is I told you so because
everybody's going to interpret this you
know the the pro-russian people in the
west they're going to say Well the West
cause this and now look we've got
potential instability blah blah blah
because that's their narrative uh and
people who think this is Russia's fault
are going to think well Vladimir Putin
made a bad mistake which in my opinion
he did and Harry Palm says
hypothetically Russia withdrawals or
losers Ukraine NATO enters Ukraine USA
those missiles in Ukraine thoughts he
says oh by the way I don't smoke weed
thank you very much go Trump oh there's
a whole mixed bag of messages in there
yeah uh go Trump I don't smoke weed and
what was the original question so the
original question is uh do you think
that he put the case that Russia will
withdraw from Ukraine uh Ukraine will
then become part of NATO Russia uh us
will then put their missiles in Ukraine
well as you well know I have said from
literally day one yeah the best solution
here is uh not the look it's not the
best solution because if you're
Ukrainian it's not the best solution for
you and if you're Russian it's not the
best solution for you but from a neutral
perspective
uh the best way to end this war is for
Ukraine to make some small territorial
concessions for Ukraine to accept that
Crimea isn't coming back into the fold
of Ukraine and in exchange for Ukraine
to get long-term security and there's
only one way to give them that which is
NATO now would if I if I were advising
people would I want them to then put U.S
missiles in Ukraine no no I I think that
you know NATO membership would be about
protecting Ukraine it's not about you
know putting its missiles U.S missiles
or U.S defensive missiles because
they're actually in effect the same
thing from a geopolitical from a game
theory perspective
because if you and I have a gun pointer
at each other each uh you know an
offensive missile is like a gun but a
defensive missile system is like the
ability to switch your gun off it's the
same thing right effectively I can shoot
you without being shot back
um so yeah I I hope that isn't what the
US does because that would just be
aggravating the situation necessarily
but I personally think that the solution
long term is for Ukraine to be part of
NATO because otherwise this is what I
keep saying to people I will be back
here again in a few years because that's
what happened in 2014 right Rush a bit
off chunks of Ukraine nobody did
anything so they came back for more the
only way this ends in the long run is
for Ukraine to secure its future and
that is a membership of an alliance
that's going to give it safety
Andrew Broughton says do you think this
uh situation could bring an end to the
war in Ukraine and if it did how does a
West build relate rebuild relations with
Russia
uh well because it ended as quickly as
it did I don't know the impact that it's
going to make on the war in Ukraine so
far it doesn't seem like it's made any
sort of decisive impact
um and then how do we build relations
well that really depends on how the the
Ukraine conflict is actually a result
yeah okay uh Juan Felipe
uh Ola says how would this attempt or
this attempt to affect Russia's internal
order
well so far it doesn't seem to have had
too much of an impact so we we just
don't know because it ended as quickly
as it did cool yeah uh Maria says uh
says a lot of talk about the possibility
of this might have been a smoke scoot
green to redirect attention away from
something not sure I believe this but
any idea what this something could be
well I don't believe it so I therefore
don't have any idea of what that thing
could be yeah please remember to keep on
sending the Super Chat Francis why don't
we I think we're almost there to be
honest yeah in terms of we've done over
an hour so why don't we do another 10
minutes yep uh if you want to ask any
questions send in locals message it was
put post on locals there's a post for
that there if you're a supporter and if
you're not you probably should be if you
enjoy this show there's 10 000 of you
watching at least 10 of you like a
thousand should be on locals I would say
in fact 100 of you yeah ten thousand
people head on over to locals right now
or send a super chat here and we'll do
about 10 more minutes of your questions
yeah absolutely so uh gift broadcast and
this is his super chat or their Super
Chat rumors are spreading amongst
Russian law enforcement organs at shoigu
has allegedly been detained how would
weak would put Putin look if this is
true very very weak I mean you should
have seen my face when you read that out
I I don't believe that for a second uh I
mean if that turns out to be true then
progression has got his way and that
means he did a deal with Putin to pull
back
in order to get shoigu arrested
I haven't
I'm not I'm just checking all the
different channels and information that
I usually check I haven't heard anything
about that whatsoever but again think
about this that would be a massive
undermining of Putin's Authority I I
don't think that's true though
personally uh Marco cabbage who is a uh
a real fan of the show and a great
supporter Love to You Marco says been a
while wouldn't be surprised if Putin
tries to make himself Emperor after this
Palpatine stole he did run though people
will not forget that
Emperor after this I think he's a lot
more worried about just yeah staying
where he is to be honest with you Marco
but thank you for the Super Chat and
thank you for being a law supporter over
I appreciate it I feel fresher 3.0 says
uh the whole outside marks go is the
plan regroup and see who inside Moscow
will either step aside or join the
rebels it is not over
well there you go well I guess we'll
we'll be back here tomorrow talking
about yeah exactly someone's a fan of
the Wagner group uh
so locals this is from our locals and
this is dibinism or diben says does kk
think the collapse of the kakova dam was
incompetence or malice well he was blown
up so he wasn't incompetent yeah yeah a
friend of mine who dabbles in stalks
bought a lot of agricultural stocks
expecting wheat prices to jump up in a
few years
okay yeah well you know like they say
when there's blood on the streets uh
buying diamonds yeah oh yeah so I
totally missed my job
I would say is my question is for
Constantine have you lost any friends or
family or friends in the war
um
I haven't lost any family or friends but
I many of my friends have lost family
and friends yeah uh Gordon Lizzy says
how much should Beauty now worry about
Russian nationalists becoming the
biggest threat to his continued control
over the Russian State
um well I don't know who he means by
Russian nationalists exactly I mean I
mean Putin's a Russian nationalist isn't
he
Russia is very complicated Russia is not
a nation Russia is an Empire and so
Russia has some nationalists in it but
they're not really a prominent force in
Russia not least because so many
um
so many units that have been fighting in
the war and not ethnic Russians
um so I I don't see Russian nationalists
as very strong it doesn't mean that they
couldn't emerge a strong nationalist
movement but there isn't one at the
moment yeah okay so uh it's funny mate I
love the comments uh from just from
random as what it's literally like one
person saying Russia is over cry about
it okay and then someone else says I'm
I'm massively biased against Russia I
suppose we're striking the right balance
we are striking we are striking the
right balance uh Andy Vogel Vogel
voguely ask a very good question who
benefits the most from Putin's unseating
what are the chances the wealthy
oligarchs whoever assets Frozen are in
Frozen sorry the people who are least
happy about this conflict are the
oligarchs they had nothing to gain and
everything to lose so uh I have no doubt
that precaution will be in contact with
some of them for sure and uh a lot of
them will want this water end one way or
another as quickly as possible so that
that would definitely be a part of it
yeah it's going to be very interesting
because evgenic ocean is going to have
to do some kind of Public Announcement
as to what's happened in his raising in
his thinking behind it
behind this well mutiny
surely he's going to have to make a
public statement Putin no uh yeah
well he has said he's pulling back this
troops he doesn't want to spill blood
blah blah blah that's what he said so
far and I guess we'll just have to wait
and see how that yeah but you do think
that it's going to be he's got to have
give some explanation as to his actions
he can't just do this and not explain
why surely well he explained why he said
our unit was about to be disbanded so we
might we had a March for justice towards
Moscow and then we realized blood would
be spilled we decided not to spill blood
well March for justice I mean that's a
way of putting it okay Canon said hi
Constantine I read some tweets earlier
which seemed to suggest that China may
be tempted to claim some territory in
Eastern Russia in the event that this
Rebellion turned out to be successful I
can't see how that would happen giving
up both countries have uh nuclear
weapons well the way it would happen is
if Russia started to disintegrate and
there was nobody fully in charge of
those nuclear weapons uh that would be
the time for China to strike I don't
think China would necessarily want to do
that but China has territorial claims in
Russia's Far East for sure and that's
one of the fears in Russia if Russia
gets too weak Chinese will take
advantage which they may or may not do
right so what do you mean by that they
have claims in the forest well there are
territories of Russia that China would
like to to have under its control they
have as a result of actually a lot of
migration High Chinese populations
there's some historical stuff that I I'm
not an expert on
um that they also have claims against
certain territories in the Russia as far
east so
um they may well uh in fact I'm
revealing my historical ignorance but I
I think during World War II Russia the
Soviet Union may have occupied parts of
what was in China I don't remember very
well and I could be wrong about that so
uh just pass on that one okay I think
that is pretty much it all right well uh
thanks everybody for joining us make
sure you subscribe and smash the like
button on this before you leave uh well
done for hosting this Francis and uh
thank you for being with us we will see
you uh very soon with more brilliant
interviews as always and our raw shows
as well uh take care and we'll see you
on locals